[Music]
you can turn me on this romance is on so
here's how the couple's Bahamas getaway
got started on Friday JLo flew to Miami
with kids the source tells us she
dropped Max and Emmy off at the Dada
Marc Anthony's home and then met up with
a rock the two boarded a private jet
which landed at 9:30 p.m. then took a
limo here to the super exclusive Baker's
Bay Golf and Ocean Club where J rod had
a three to five million dollar private
seafront villa
on Sunday 47 year old JLo posted this
selfie on Instagram then deleted it 60
seconds later it appears to be the 41
year old former Yankee nuzzling her ear
love starts inside you you got to love
yourself first and then you can maybe
have a good relationship with somebody
else of course
j-rod is our favorite new couple of the
moment but who do we have to thank for
hooking these two up a source close to
Alex tells us quote they have a couple
mutual friends who kind of put this idea
together Alex went to see Jennifer's
show in Vegas and that's where it really
started the relationship is very new JLo
is scheduled to be back on stage in
Vegas Wednesday a rod has a sports
conference at the end of the month so as
the when their next date will be our
source says both their schedules are so
crazy they will meet up and time allows
[Music]
you